according to this study if I was doing  less laundry and less dishes we would be  having more sex women are less likely to  want to [ __ ] the guy if they're making  more money so we like a very sexy couple  was do you want to take your coat off  and stay a while I think I'm okay with  my coat on oh no no I got it  think of my vagina is a beautiful sexy  thing you made out with your dick I sure  did there is his that's his he's got  your little baby to chew  si senorita oh my god I don't think I  can move we're 15 years of relationship  he's gotten as I am wrong hard it's  gotta be by about more than that I don't  want to [ __ ] you there's something else  missing hi there I'm a construction  worker right so why am i fixing your  sink  [Music]  I've been on four dates - or bar date -  or coffee dates and the two bar dates I  slept with them that's the difference  between coffee and vodka  [Music]  you